welcome back to 8701
so we switch gear now and talk about
quantum electrodynamics
um qed and we'll start the discussion
by going back to three wave equations
now you could argue that we are
interested in collisions and we're
interested in the case of particles so
why do we discuss three wave equations
now the theory we discussed last week
which we used in order to
get a hold on finding diagrams and
calculations was very simplified and one
of the aspects not considered in this
theory
was the fact that particles carry spin
so we had a theory which
you know only was applicable to scales
now by
walking through wave equations we can
see how we can
incorporate or
uh make use of the fact that particles
actually do carry spin
so let's do this one by one so we start
off with our relativistic energy
momentum
relation e square is equal to p square
plus m square
um we express energy and momentum we are
quantum mechanical operators
and so immediately by putting this in we
find this equation here
which is the so-called klein garden wave
equation
so good so if you look at this equation
we see that the second derivative here
in time there's no derivative in space
so there's an
asymmetry between space and time and
that is
uh not a really useful feature of our
wave equation as we as we
want them to be lauren's invariant for
example
so what we want is a first order
equation
[Music]
in both derivatives so we you know just
start writing this down in general terms
and then make sure
that this equation holds to the
relativistic equation we just saw on the
previous slide
we just write this down here we have a
first derivative time and the first
derivative of space
let me just say that's a constant
between those two relating those two
um so the sigmas are just unknown
constants
so if you now try to find by squaring
this try to find the klein gordon
equation and relate the coefficients
how you find this relationship here for
the sigma square
uh all the same and equal to one but you
also see that
um the sigma is the antique coming
commutate sorry um which is not possible
for numbers
so so sigmas need to be matrixes
you also see that this is only holding
true here for m equal to zero
so this equation here is true for a
massless particle
all right so if we then try to find uh
solutions for those relations we find
that you know
they can be fulfilled by the two by two
powly mattresses
you might have seen in this car seen
this already in a discussion or
hopefully i've seen this in the
discussion of atomic physics
and there um those polymattresses
associate spin to uh
electrons so this is exactly what we
have in mind here
um also now using this definition we can
rewrite the
vale equations to energy times the field
is equal to minus sigma times the
momentum times the field
and find the second equation where just
the sign flips
those the chi here and the phi are
sphenols
they are two dimensional vectors and the
sigmas are our party matrices
good so we have the relational point but
we can go
a step further now you want to introduce
a mastermind as well i said that you
know those sort of masses particles so
we're going to introduce masses
look we can rewrite this equation and
introduce this mass term here again with
the coefficient
and we find now this
alpha here being sorry so this
phi here is a four component spinor and
it stands for the particle it's
anti-particle
and the two spin states so that's
combining those two equations we had
here
we will see one is for particles and one
is for anti-particles for the two spin
states so we combine this in one
equation and we added
with master so if you try to find the
solutions here you find that
alpha is a matrix four by four matrix
which has
the sigma the poly matrices and the off
diagonal
elements and beta is a diagonal
matrix four by four matrix with
identity on the upper two components and
minus one in the lower
component so now
with this we can this is already the
direct equation we can rewrite the
direct equation in a covariant form
where you have just defined a new matrix
here
so-called gamma matrix which you build
out of
this matrix better and alpha which i
defined on the previous slide
good so good so we have this this new
matrix this new equation here which is
the dirac equation and it holds for
particles
to spin state for example spin half
states
and there it holds for particles which
have masses
so that's great so this is now our
starting point for the discussion the
next lecture we'll look at
solutions of this equation